- [Narrator] Finland is
now officially a member
of the world's largest military alliance.
(people clapping)
- This is an historic day.
We welcome Finland as a
newest member of our alliance.
- [Narrator] The Nordic
nation completed one
of the fastest accession
processes in NATO's history.
Finland applied to join in
response to Russia's invasion
of Ukraine in February 2022.
In the process,
Finland ended its decades-old policy
of military non-alignment.
- It will change Russia's
posture towards Europe
and NATO in general in the future.
- [Narrator] Here's what
the historic expansion means
for the alliance and security in Europe.
First of all, Finland
adds more than 800 miles
to NATO's border with Russia.
It also extends the area in which NATO
can conduct its operations.
The territory spans
about 1,000 miles from the
Baltic Sea to the Arctic.
- Finland joining NATO also means
that the NATO alliance comes
closer to the Kola Peninsula,
which has great strategic
importance for Russia.
It's where many of its nuclear
capabilities are based.
- [Narrator] And Finland
doesn't come empty handed
as it's one of Europe's best defended
and best armed countries.
- Finland has maintained a posture
against Russia where it
was ready for a conflict.
It can mobilize over 800,000 troops
and it's also continued
to modernize its military.
In the past decade,
it's received surface to
air missiles, rocket systems
and it's even received
the F-35s from the US.
- The Kremlin's decision
to invade Ukraine radically
changed Finnish public opinion
on the country's non-aligned
defense doctrine.
In May 2022, support for
NATO membership lept to 76%,
a fundamental shift from
30% in January that year
just before the invasion.
And for Russian president Vladimir Putin,
Finland's accession is a
major strategic setback.
- There is definitely a sort
of a paradox in this, in
these developments, given
that we know that Vladimir
Putin wants to divide NATO
and the Western alliance.
But what he's actually facing now
is a more united Western front than ever.
- President Putin wanted
to slam NATO's door shut.
Today we show the world that he failed.
- [Narrator] Russia said
NATO's enlargement is a threat
to its security and national interests.
(Sergei speaking in Russian)
- [Narrator] Finland's
membership of NATO came
after months of diplomatic
disputes with Turkey.
Finland applied to join the Alliance
at the same time as
Sweden, but Turkey alleged
the two Northern European
countries had connections
to Kurdish militant groups
fighting the Turkish state.
Eventually, Ankara ratified
Finland's membership
but Sweden is still waiting
to join the Alliance,
which needs the approval
of all existing members
to accept any new entrants.
- Sweden definitely hopes to be a member
of NATO by the end of the year.
- Our persistent efforts
for a rapid Swedish
membership will continue.
(dramatic music)